y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen para destacar los
temas relacionados con la pandemia del
cob y 19 en nuestro continente soy
santiago lópez gonzález y a continuación
les presento los temas que vamos a
tratar en esta edición
el gobierno de eeuu anunció que enviará
millones de vacunas contra el cob y 19 a
países de américa latina como parte de
un compromiso del presidente joe biden
de asumir un rol de liderazgo para poner
fin a la pandemia en nuestra región y
también en el mundo la decisión ha sido
llamada diplomacia de las vacunas un
fenómeno que también vimos por parte de
china y de rusia con un invitado
especial aquí vamos a analizar este tema
la donación de este arsenal de vacunas y
que puede haber detrás de esa iniciativa
más allá de las buenas intenciones de la
casa blanca
en un hecho también destacado el repunte
de casos de contagio de las últimas
semanas en méxico indica que el país
encara una tercera ola de contagios
debido a buena parte de las variantes
que han empezado a llegar en ese país
incluida la variante delta una de las
más contagiosas méxico ya comenzará a
reportar en los próximos días ya comenzó
a reportar mejor hospitales y unidades
de cuidados intensivos saturados y un
aumento en el número de casos hasta
9.000 contagios diarios en sólo 24 horas
han comenzado a reportar veremos cómo
está la situación y también con nuestros
corresponsales en brasil perú y paraguay
veremos cómo está el panorama general en
esos países en algunos de ellos han
comenzado a bajar levemente los números
de contagios gracias al avance de la
vacunación en otros como en el caso de
paraguay recibieron el mayor lote de
vacunas que haya llegado a ese país
suramericano a través de una donación de
eeuu esto dará un impulso a ese rezagado
plan de vacunación son algunos de los
temas tenemos muchos más pues
simplemente comenzamos y lo tenemos que
hacer con
las cifras destacadas de esta semana y
son los más de 4 millones de personas
que ya fallecieron en el mundo por
cuenta del cobi 19 según datos de la oms
y del conteo de la universidad johns
hopkins se llega a este oscuro hito en
la historia de la humanidad mientras las
diferentes naciones avanzan a un ritmo
muy desigual con las campañas de
vacunación también cuando estamos en
medio de la preocupación mundial
generalizada por supuesto por el auge de
la variante delta que está causando
estragos en países como indonesia e
israel en donde hay repuntes de
contagios también por ejemplo países
como el reino unido y otros países de
europa han registrado un aumento de
casos más de 4 millones de muertos
equivale a la población de un país como
georgia en el cáucaso y es una población
mayor que la población que tiene uruguay
la organización mundial de la salud
reiteró que la lucha contra la pandemia
no ha terminado y manifestó su
preocupación ante lo que considera es
una prematura reapertura de las
economías a nivel mundial bueno en el
país no estamos en un buen momento en
áfrica un aumento del 16.7 por ciento de
los casos en siete días
en la región mediterránea aumentaron en
un 16.4 por ciento los casos en europa
en un 33% 18.6 en el sureste asiático un
10% en el pacífico oeste
la única región que tiende a bajar es la
de las américas hay más de una docena de
países que tienen curvas epidémicas que
son casi verticales en este momento casi
verticales esto no es una situación en
la que deberíamos estar si tenemos
herramientas y manos
también destacado la vacuna cubana
abdalá que tiene más del 92 por ciento
de eficacia de acuerdo con los ensayos
clínicos recibió la autorización para su
uso de emergencia en cuba de esta manera
de la vacuna podrá ser inoculada en todo
el territorio de esta isla del caribe
tras recibir esta autorización de uso de
emergencia por parte del ente regulador
en temas sanitarios allí en cuba se
trata de la primera vacuna desarrollada
en américa latina en alcanzar esta
condición de uso veamos
latinoamérica ya tiene su primera vacuna
autóctona contra el cubil 19 el fármaco
cubano abdalá recibió este viernes la
autorización de uso de emergencia en el
país caribeño así podrá acelerarse la
inoculación en la isla que no celebró
ningún convenio con otras vacunas
extranjeras podemos estar diciendo que
tenemos la primera vacuna
con autorizo de uso de emergencia
otorgado por la agencia cubana
ninguno duro de medicamentos abdalá
tiene una eficacia del 90 y 2.2 por
ciento contra el riesgo de contraer kobe
con síntomas según el grupo farmacéutico
estatal bio cuba farm a la ventaja de
abdalá es que puede almacenar siente 2 y
8 grados celsius un elemento
significativo en américa latina donde la
refrigeración a alto nivel necesaria
para otras vacunas es difícil un segundo
candidato cubano a la vacuna bautizado
como soberana 2 también está en la recta
final tras lograr una eficacia del 91
por ciento en las próximas semanas
podría ser aprobado también su uso de
emergencia con lo cual la isla contaría
con dos vacunas más de un millón de los
11 millones de cubanos ya han recibido
la pauta completa de abdalá o soberana 2
y el propósito de las autoridades
sanitarias es tener al cien por ciento
de los habitantes de la isla vacunados
antes de que acabe el año
[Música]
él ha estado trabajando intensamente
los elementos productivos incrementar
las producciones para bueno seguir el
proceso de vacunación a nuestra a
nuestra población el país también espera
vender sus fórmulas en el extranjero el
gobierno venezolano que ha comprado 12
millones de dosis de abdalá sin embargo
aún podrían pasar meses hasta que abdalá
alcance la homologación de la ms que le
otorgue la aceptación internacional
lo avanzábamos también en el sumario de
temas del programa eeuu anunció que
enviará millones de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 a países de américa latina en
un nuevo capítulo de la llamada
diplomacia de las vacunas como ya
sucedió con china y con rusia las
donaciones son muy generosas y en este
momento pues la ayuda le sirve a
cualquier país que la reciba en américa
latina' el aporte es grande veamos las
cifras brasil recibirá o recibió ya tres
millones de dosis colombia 2.5 millones
perú y ecuador 2 millones de dosis
honduras y el salvador 1.5 millones de
dosis méxico recibió 1.3 millones de
dosis ganará un millón paraguay recibió
un millón de dosis y uruguay también ya
recibió 500 mil dosis de vacunas
pero qué es lo que hay más allá de las
buenas intenciones que pueda tener la
casa blanca para ayudar a superar la
pandemia estas donaciones también
tendrían que ver con el regreso de eeuu
al escenario internacional como un actor
líder vamos a analizar ese tema con
manuel alejandro arriarán o raydán mejor
él es el docente de la universidad
externado de colombia es máster en
diplomacia y resolución de conflictos
nos atiende desde la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia alejandro bienvenido gracias
por acompañarnos en el programa y cuál
podría ser entonces esa estrategia que
tiene estados unidos para decidir
entonces donar estos enormes lotes de
vacunas a diferentes países varios de
ellos en américa latina como veíamos en
la gráfica
buenas noches y muchas gracias por
invitación consideró que la entrega de
donaciones de sal bajo un gas así parte
de una gran estrategia una estrategia
que es de gran escala y para un periodo
prolongado por parte de eeuu y esta
donación apunta a equiparar las acciones
diplomáticas que realizado china y rusia
con la vacuna y que después hay que
olvidar que cuando surgen las vacunas en
eeuu y en el reino unido y alemania esos
países lo que hacen es acaparar las lo
que hizo rusia chino distinto puedes
donar la sí pues digamos que este es un
primer punto entre esta estrategia
considero que la segunda es demostrar
que eeuu sigue presente nación
internacional y que quiere demostrar a
la comunidad internacional que en eeuu
aún puede proveer bienes públicos como
las vacunas y finalmente yo considero
que la entrega de eso es posicionar la
imagen también de eeuu no hay que
olvidar que el 23 de junio de este año
por ejemplo los legisladores tanto
demócratas como republicanos en la
cámara de representantes estaban
discutiendo en el comité asuntos
exteriores
solicitando exponerle o etiquetar todos
los las
la vacuna con la bandera de los estados
unidos es decir que con la botellita de
la vacuna leia era ponerle la bandera de
los estados fines para posicionar a este
país en el ejército internacional dentro
de la guerra también alejandro de la
administración del presidente
joe biden ha sido poco clara ha sido
poco contundente en el tipo de relación
que quiere tener con la región de
américa latina esta donación de vacunas
puede ser un primer paso de acercamiento
con la región porque así como vemos que
le donó a algunos países hay otros que
no figuran en ninguna de las listas por
ejemplo nicaragua y venezuela y también
argentina
y pues la verdad considero que la
donación de las vacunas es una acción
que apunta más a la estrategia general
de los estados unidos y esto lo dijo que
hoy digamos que américa latina como
veces santiago no está entre la gente
prioritaria del presidente vaivén y eso
lo podemos evidenciar por ejemplo con la
evaluación anual de amenazas de la
oficina inteligencia en su informe abril
de este año y así también la guía
estratégica de seguridad nacional que
pues digamos que le ubica o les traiga
muy poco espacio américa latina no
obstante consideró que los programas de
asistencia extranjera es de eeuu están
conducidos bajo los principios de
acciones versiones correctas e
inteligentes eeuu quieres dar con estas
vacunas estás describiendo américa
latina no es el punto central dentro de
la estrategia eeuu si ha sido lo que
centroamérica y digamos que más que
todos los países de las comunidades
caribes estos países son fundamentales
porque de acuerdo a la administración
nacional de océanos y te apartamos
fabricar eeuu consideran que existe un
60 por ciento de probabilidad que este
año haya una temporada de huracanes más
fuertes en el sentido eeuu al entregarle
estas vacunas a centroamérica
evitar más daños en la región y evitar
que van de ganado y anden a tu país
alejandro me sigo despegando del tema
médico y juntando me un poco más al tema
político qué impacto puede tener en la
comunidad internacional este anuncio de
eeuu de donar cerca de 500 millones de
dosis a varios países del mundo estamos
analizando el caso de américa latina
pero también van a donar a otros países
como por ejemplo bangladesh a varias
naciones en asia central de otros países
del sudeste asiático
bueno el impacto principal en el
exterior es que va a dejar un mensaje a
la comunidad eso lo vimos en el g7
elegir su visita a la unión europa de la
otan es que estados unidos no solamente
regresó al escenario internacional sino
que llegó para quedarse y yo creo que
ese es el mensaje que busca eeuu con
esta donación también consideró que con
estas donaciones buscan es fortalecer
las relaciones amicales históricas con
sus aliados y finalmente creo que lo que
le apunta con esta donación y el impacto
político es decir a la comunidad
internacional que eeuu nuevamente la
apuesta a la cooperación ya las
relaciones multilaterales y no a las
unilaterales que el psoe bajo la
administración de tron que fuera las que
primará cuál puede ser lo que espera o
qué es lo que esperaría a washington a
cambio de estas donaciones que esperan
en retribuciones es un ángel y te
pregunta santiago y es que hoy panel
para responder está este interrogatorio
pues hay que saber que la visión que
tienen los estrategas de eeuu y es que
ellos ven el mundo como si fuera una
guerra 2.0 yo no la considero aquí no
obstante como la visión de washington es
que el mundo entra una a una guerra de
guerra fría 2.0 lo que eeuu busca con
esta entrega
desde vacunas es fortalecer su relación
con estos países para que estos fáciles
países que reciben las vacunas pues
puedan respaldar al presidente bailar en
las diferentes mesas de negociación y
temas de negociación que va a abordar y
por eso le decía santiago que la agenda
y la estrategia del presidente hoy tiene
es amplia no porque además de estos
cuatro años de presidente hoy le quiere
modificar algunos temas como la reforma
la organización mundial del comercio o
la organización mundial de la salud o
los suministros de cadenas que lo quiere
modificar y el impuesto global a la
sociedad entre otras y para hacer esos
cambios grandes cambios con un impacto
dentro del escenario internacional
claramente hoy se tiene claro que este
debe tener un apoyo de sus países
aliados y considero que esto es una
manera de pavimentar unas relaciones con
estos países para que estos países
posteriormente lo apoyen en estos
cambios y en los organismos
internacionales para terminar le
pregunto en las crisis mundiales como
por ejemplo en la segunda guerra mundial
después de ella eeuu se alzó como un
gran líder mundial como una potencia
también como en cierta forma como el
país que salvó al mundo de la amenaza
del nazismo en este en esta coyuntura en
la que estamos
cree usted
eeuu se está tratando de seguir el mismo
guión de alzarse a nivel mundial
entonces como un líder en esta coyuntura
sanitaria en la que estamos pero el
escenario a nivel diplomático es muy
distinto y así lo ha enseñado china a lo
largo de los últimos años en la forma en
que este país asiático se relaciona con
el resto del mundo
santiago sólo de dos maneras la primera
que creo que eeuu en estos momentos más
que liberar al mundo de alguna amenaza
como fue el comunismo durante la guerra
fría o el terrorismo como fue durante
los primeros diez años del siglo 21 yo
creo que eeuu con esto lo que está
buscando es salvar su hegemonía y su
liderazgo mundial digamos que por ese
motivo está su estrategia para estos
cuatro años es bastante amplia eeuu que
es no hay que olvidar lo ha estado en un
proceso declive progresivo y de la
crisis financiera del 2008 y lo que eso
le ha permitido lo que ha tenido como
consecuencia el debilitamiento de la
estructura hegemónica de estados unidos
en el mundo
la estructura de mónica como que se
materializan en las capacidades
económicas industriales discapacidad
materiales las institucionales en la
ágil y la creación al es decir las
concepciones del orden liberal
democrático estos trece elementos que
componen lo que es una estructura
hegemónica es el sistema internacional
se ha visto debilitado eeuu y en ese
sentido creo que eeuu busca fortalecer
internamente para poder así tener una
mayor agencia de acción en el género
internacional manuel alejandro reirán
desde la ciudad de bogotá gracias por
este análisis para la audiencia
24 gracias por acompañarnos en el
programa ryan ya no se me olvida nunca
más y vamos a las cifras veamos como
está la situación de contagios y de
fallecidos en diferentes países de
américa latina así están las cosas para
el cierre de esta semana vamos a ver los
cinco países con la mayor cantidad de
casos en nuestra región es decir el top
5 y comenzamos con brasil que cierra
esta semana con más de 18 millones 900
mil casos confirmados más de 530 mil
personas han fallecido allí argentina
tiene más de 4.600.000 casos y ya más de
97.000 900 personas han fallecido este
país se aproxima a las 100.000 víctimas
mortales en tercer lugar está colombia
con más de 4 millones 400 mil casos
confirmados en este país 111 mil
personas han perdido la vida en el
puesto número 4 es para la república
mexicana con más de 2.5 millones de
casos confirmados y como lo decíamos
está enfrentando ya la tercera ola más
de 234 mil personas han fallecido allí
en mexico y para cerrar este top 5 está
perú con 2 millones de casos y más
90.000 fallecidos
vamos a ir entonces a brasil a lo largo
de las semanas les hemos reportado la
situación en ese país suramericano ya lo
decíamos es un país que es uno de los
más críticos en la región uno de los más
críticos a nivel mundial encabeza el top
5 con la mayor cantidad de casos y
también se habla ya de la llegada de
algunas variantes de el kobe 19 vamos
entonces hasta río de janeiro allí está
valeria saccone para conocer las
novedades valeria cuáles son los avances
en torno a esa investigación que está en
marcha y en brasil
que lo estábamos mencionando está
avanzando en torno a ese intento de
compra y también luego la cancelación de
un pedido de un lote de vacunas de
kóvacs in de la india
ya son dos los escándalos relacionados
con la compra de vacunas en brasil la
semana pasada conocíamos el caso de la
kovác sin la vacuna importada y
regularmente de la india y delante de
las denuncias y el gobierno de brasil
decidió interrumpir la compra esta
semana en la comisión de investigación
de la gestión de la pandemia hemos
sabido que había una empresa fantasma
que ofreció al ministerio de sanidad una
gran cantidad de vacunas
astrazéneca también importadas de la
india según denuncian algunas personas
involucradas en esta trama la oferta era
vender esta vacuna a un precio más alto
del mercado y quedarse la empresa con un
dólar por cada dosis en este momento en
la comisión de la pandemia se están
escuchando a varios testigos y a
personas supuestamente involucradas en
esta trama que según el presidente de la
comisión
omar aziz estarían mintiendo y por esta
razón esa semana él decretó prisión para
roberto díaz el ex director de logística
del ministerio de sanidad porque según
él habría mentido durante todas
declaración ha sido un acto de fuerza
para avisar a los las personas que
acuden a esta comisión que no pueden
mentir
roberto díaz ha pagado una fianza de 210
dólares para no ir a la cárcel pero la
tensión entre los poderes sigue porque
omar aziz ayer también criticó la
supuesta implicación de militares en
esta trama de corrupción y desvío de
dinero hay que recordar que el gobierno
de jair bolsonaro tiene el número más
grande de militares en cargos públicos
incluso mayor que durante la dictadura
militar son más de seis mil cargos y las
declaraciones de asís han hecho mella en
las fuerzas armadas ayer hubo un
comunicado tanto de las fuerzas armadas
como del ministerio de defensa
criticando las palabras de asís y
mientras ya vemos que esta situación con
turbada empieza a tener una reflejo en
los sondeos de opinión porque acaban de
salir unos datos y el 51% de los
brasileños
jair bolsonaro hace unas semanas era el
45 o sea esta situación está impactando
claramente en la popularidad de
bolsonaro todo el tema relacionado con
la pandemia de kobe 19 ha impactado la
imagen del presidente brasileño valeria
ahora si vamos a las cifras después de
varios meses de tener récords de
contagios de hospitalizaciones de
personas fallecidas cómo está la
situación allí en brasil porque
recientemente se han registrado unos
pequeños descensos que es lo que está
sucediendo allí es entonces por el
avance de la vacunación se debe a esto
brasil ha superado los 500 30.000
muertos una cifra que impacta sin
embargo la buena noticia es que por
primera vez desde el mes de marzo la
media diaria de muertes ha bajado se
sitúa más o menos en 1500 muertos por
día todavía en mucho pero mucho menos
que los que se registró en el mes de
abril cuando se alcanzó la cifra
espantosa de 4300 muertos por día de
hecho en la última semana la mortalidad
ha bajado un 20% y los expertos esperan
y calculan que va a seguir bajando como
efecto directo de la vacunación que
sigue lenta pero avanza ya hay 80
millones de brasileños es decir el 38
por ciento de la población que ha
recibido la primera dosis y un 14 por
ciento que ha recibido las dos dosis y
que está completamente inmunizados
mientras tanto ciudades como sao paulo
han empezado a flexibilizar las medidas
de cuarentena por ejemplo la ciudad más
grande de brasil y también la más
afectada por el coronavirus permitirá
ahora que bares y restaurantes estén
abiertos hasta las 11 de la noche y que
también puedan tener una
equivalente al 60 por ciento valeria
quiero preguntarle por el avance de la
variante del tie y en brasil hay casos
reportados en sao paulo y también en río
de janeiro que dicen las autoridades
entonces
la variante de alta preocupa y mucho a
las autoridades sanitarias de brasilia
sabemos que hay varios casos en río de
janeiro san pablo en el estado del mar
añado de momento parece que son todos
casos importados es decir de personas
que viajaron al extranjero contra jerga
y el virus y volvieron enfermas sin
embargo el riesgo de una tercera ola tan
mortífera o incluso más que la segunda
es real y por eso las autoridades
sanitarias de algunos estados federados
están pensando en reducir el intervalo
entre la primera la segunda dosis de las
vacunas especialmente de la fisher y de
la astrazéneca que según el protocolo
sanitario de brasil tienen un intervalo
de tres meses el problema en realidad es
poderse abastecer con los inmunizantes
porque brasil lo hemos contado varias
veces es una potencia sanitaria tienen
gran capacidad de aplicar vacunas en
larga escala y problema es la compra de
este bien escaso y deseado por todos los
países del mundo entonces en los
próximos semanas y meses sabremos cuál
es la real capacidad de negociación de
un gobierno
aquejado encima por unos escándalos de
corrupción precisamente con la compra de
vacunas
pues lo veremos valeria cuál es esa
capacidad de negociación que tiene el
gobierno brasileño para comprar más
vacunas gracias por este reporte desde
la ciudad de río de janeiro vamos ahora
hasta méxico este país está presentando
un repunte de los contagios de el
coronavirus además fueron reportados
casos relacionados con diferentes
variantes del cob y 19 algunos de estos
casos podrían ser importados ante la
llegada de cientos de turistas por el
inicio de las vacaciones del verano
boreal vamos a profundizar en este tema
por eso conectamos con mario' carbonell
en la capital mexicana hola mario pues
ya lo estábamos mencionando la tercera
ola parece que ya está instalándose allí
en méxico ha comenzado hay muchos casos
de contagio como está el ritmo de
contagio de fallecidos allí en la
república mexicana y qué dicen las
autoridades sanitarias
así es estamos ya en plena tercera ola
reconocida tanto por las autoridades
mexicanas como por la opc y es que la
curva epidémica ha aumentado a 27 por
ciento esta semana se han tenido récord
de contagios en un solo día por ejemplo
el jueves se reportaron más de 9.400
casos en las últimas 24 horas esto es
mil más que un día anterior y son cifras
que no se tenían desde febrero pasado la
ciudad de mexico la península de yucatán
estados como sinaloa oaxaca y baja
california sur son las entidades de
mayor contagio en esta última entidad la
capital la paz decidió cerrar sus playas
hasta el próximo 15 de julio para
intentar contener los contagios en la
capital del país la jefa de gobierno
claudia sheinbaum admitió que hay un
alza en las hospitalizaciones sin
embargo este incremento de contagios en
todo el país según las autoridades no va
acompañado de un aumento en los
fallecimientos porque es a la población
joven a la que más está afectando esta
tercera ola a los de 18 y entre 18 y 39
el subsecretario de salud o culo pez
gatel ha hecho un llamado a no des
convertir los hospitales para seguir
dando atención prioritaria a pacientes
con mario' con este panorama entonces
como está avanzando la vacunación
sabemos que allí ya hay registro abierto
de modo general para las personas
adultas para que el que se quiere
vacunar puede asistir al centro de
vacunación que desee y allí recibe su
vacuna
al país han llegado alrededor de 64
millones de vacunas pero al más reciente
corte se han aplicado poco más de 49
millones esto es una diferencia de 14
millones de vacunas entre las que han
llegado y las que se han aplicado esto
ha generado algunas dudas algunas
críticas las autoridades aseguran que es
falso que se estén almacenando las
vacunas y argumentan que el proceso de
distribución hasta los puntos de
vacunación tarda unos 5 días sin embargo
pues es una cantidad considerable que ha
despertado inquietud sobre la capacidad
del gobierno para aplicar vacunas a un
mayor ritmo actualmente se está
inoculando a la población de entre 30 y
39 años y en efecto se abrió ya el
registro para que los de 18 años en
adelante esto es toda la población
adulta del país se registre para
próximamente recibir su dosis en la
frontera norte se está acelerando la
vacunación con pzifer porque eeuu es la
condición que puso para próximamente
eventualmente
la frontera pero debe ser vacunada la
población con fans el medio que mar yo
quiero preguntarle ahora por el tema de
la variante delta que tiene varias
varios países ya en alerta ya lo
decíamos hay varios países de la región
de américa latina que la han registrado
cuales están confirmadas allí en méxico
y que han dicho de la variante del talle
es sin duda la variante delta la de
mayor preocupación porque se está
convirtiendo en la predominante al menos
en el centro del país en la ciudad de
méxico y en estados como puebla hasta
hace unos días era la variante gamma la
de mayor presencia sin embargo de
acuerdo con las autoridades y
especialistas ya la variante delta es la
de mayor predominancia el centro en el
norte es la alfa y la gamma en el sur
del país es un poco de las tres alfa
gamma y delta pero los especialistas
prevén que hacia el fin de año será sin
duda la variante delta la de mayor
presencia que es también la de más alta
transmisión la de mayor contagio y hay
algunas dudas sobre la eficacia que
tienen las diferentes vacunas para
proteger contra esta variante en méxico
se está aplicando pzifer astrazéneca
sputnik de cansinos y novak y pues las
autoridades sanitarias hacen un llamado
a que la población se aplique la que le
toque que cualquier vacuna tiene de
alguna manera protección contra las
distintas variantes y ese es el llamado
aquí
se apliquen la vacuna
varió muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de mexico vamos ahora
hasta perú allí fueron anunciadas
algunas novedades a lo largo de esta
semana el país ha impulsado el plan de
vacunación gracias a las donaciones que
ha recibido de eeuu ya que la situación
sanitaria ha mostrado leves mejorías
precisamente le vamos a preguntar sobre
este tema francisco zacarías nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de lima
hola francisco ya estamos conectados y
comienzo por preguntarle por esa
disminución en los casos de contagio ya
han comenzado a levantar algunas de las
restricciones incluso porque el panorama
sanitario en perú empieza a mejorar la
gran pregunta es a qué se debe esta
mejoría y si podemos esperar entonces un
mejor escenario para el país
santiago cordiales saludos desde lima
las autoridades peruanas anunciaron que
ninguna provincia en el país se
encuentra en el nivel de alerta extremo
y revelaron que los contagios y
fallecimientos por el kobe 19
disminuyeron 13 y 10 semanas
consecutivas respectivamente es por eso
que se han establecido dos nuevas
medidas en lima así como la mayoría de
regiones el toque de queda se iniciará
la medianoche y finalizará las 4 de la
mañana así mismo los domingos se permite
el uso de vehículos particulares solo en
las regiones sureñas de arequipa
moquegua y tacna permanecen con
restricción muy alta las autoridades
sanitarias afirman que en la última
semana los contagios de coronavirus se
redujeron a nivel en que estaban entre
la primera y segunda ola ellos confían
en que en unas dos semanas los casos se
podrían ubicar por debajo de ese nivel
pero diversos expertos le piden al
gobierno no caer en triunfalismos y
devolver las medidas restrictivas porque
calculan que en tres semanas se podría
producir una tercera ola de koi 19 en el
país y advierten que los descensos en
contagios y fallecimientos por kobe 19
podrían cambiar en pocos días a un
escenario complica
la tercera ola sigue siendo una amenaza
entonces en perú francisco pero esta
semana una buena noticia llegó un lote
procedente de eeuu donaciones de
washington a este país suramericano para
donde van a ser destinadas estas dosis
que llegaron al país pero recibió un
segundo lote de un millón de dosis de
vacunas contra el cob y 19 de
laboratorios fighter que fue donado por
eeuu
así se completaron las 2 millones de
vacunas que el gobierno de joe biden
prometió al perú para colaborar en los
esfuerzos de este país por salvar la
vida de muchos peruanos este importante
donativo permitirá acelerar el plan de
vacunación establecido por las
autoridades sanitarias precisamente el
ministerio de salud inició una maratón
de vacunación de 36 horas continuas para
impulsar la la inmunización en 200 mil
personas estarán incluidos adultos
mayores que no recibieron la primera o
segunda dosis rezagados de la primera y
adolescentes de 12 y 17 años con
comorbilidades priorizadas en las
siguientes semanas se realizarán otras
dos jornadas conocidas como vacuna ton
las autoridades
ha sido que la vacunación permitirá a la
población estar protegida ante una
eventual tercera ola de el coronavirus
francisco muchas gracias por este
reporte desde lima la capital peruana
vamos ahora a nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas de esta
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa las farmacéuticas pfizer
valiente que van a desarrollar una dosis
de refuerzo como medida preventiva
contra la variante delta del hobbit 19
ante la propagación de la variante las
compañías desarrollaron entonces una
dosis de refuerzo con el fin de proteger
aún más a las personas contra esta
variante de el coronavirus de esta forma
responden a reportes hechos por el
ministerio de salud de israel que es uno
de los países más avanzados en temas de
vacunación que indicó que pasados seis
meses la eficacia de la vacuna comienza
a disminuir en los pacientes también
destacado los juegos olímpicos de tokio
serán celebrados sin espectadores y bajo
el estado de emergencia esto después de
que el primer ministro japonés yo he
sido yo yo sí y de sugar anunciará por
cuarta vez el estado de emergencia en
tokio debido a
de casos de kobe 19 por lo que las
justas deportivas no contarán con
espectadores y marcarán la historia de
los olímpicos por ser la primera vez que
las justas deportivas son realizadas a
puerta cerrada solamente las vamos a
poder ver por televisión y retomamos el
debate vacunas contra el hobby 19
protegen contra la variante de alta pues
nuevos estudios realizados en francia-
evidencian que las vacunas están siendo
usadas o que están siendo usadas contra
kobe 19 si ofrecen protección contra la
variante delta que es ya por ejemplo la
variante mayoritaria en eeuu
y llegó la hora de hablar de la
situación en paraguay y un esperado lote
de un millón de dosis de vacunas donado
por eeuu ya llegó a este país
suramericano y se espera que esté de
inicio a una vacunación masiva aquí en
paraguay vamos a conversar entonces con
fernando box ya ls nuestro corresponsal
allí en asunción hola fernando gracias
por acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
pues de no sé entonces detalles de la
llegada de este lote allí al aeropuerto
internacional de la ciudad de asunción
para poder recibir este viernes un lote
de un millón de vacunas para ser donadas
por el gobierno de eeuu se trata del
lote de vacunas contra el coi 19 más
grande que llegó hasta ahora al país
para el almacenamiento la recepción y el
traslado de estas dosis el gobierno
recibe el apoyo de una empresa privada
debido al especial cuidado que requieren
las vacunas fighter en la llegada de
este cargamento es crucial para la lucha
contra el coronavirus en paraguay debido
a que hasta ahora sólo unas 900.000
personas fueron inmunizadas y el país
sigue en una crisis sanitaria con una de
las tasas de mortalidad por coronavirus
más altas del mundo en este momento la
llegada de estas vacunas también
significaron un alivio para el gobierno
del presidente mario abdo benítez
fuertemente criticado por su gestión
durante la pandemia hasta ahora fueron
más las vacunas que llegaron por
donaciones de gobiernos extranjeros que
aquellas que fueron efectivamente
compradas por el estado paraguayo
fernando y este cargamento de vacunas
como impulsará entonces es el rezagado
plan de vacunación nacional
este millón de vacunas permitirá un
avance importante en la campaña de
vacunación contra el cob y de paraguay
durante el fin de semana las dosis que
llegaron serán distribuidas a todos a
todas las regiones del país y los
puestos vacunatorios serán refaccionados
para poder suministrar las dosis de
facer el lunes los trabajadores
considerados esenciales por el estado
como bomberos policías militares
guardiacárceles educadores y
trabajadores de prensa recibirán una
dosis desde el martes se avanzará con la
población mayor de 35 años de edad el
gobierno anunció también ya que los
adolescentes de 12 a 17 años con
enfermedades de base también recibirán
una dosis de la fai ser el gobierno
estima que a partir de la semana que
viene unas 90.000 personas se podrán
vacunar de forma diaria contra el
coronavirus en paraguay a pesar de que
la última semana en la estadística
mostraron un descenso marcado en la
cantidad de contagios y muertes diarias
por 19 el ministerio de salud advirtió
que el país sigue en alerta roja y luego
hospitales continúan completamente
colapsados
importante este lote de vacunas para
paraguay fernando muchas gracias por
este reporte desde asunción y así
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa la
próxima semana con más derechos y más
noticias siga con france 24
[Música]